Jason Momoa uh trilogy the BOA identity
I'm Greg I'm John honest trailers screen
junkies has the Bourne trilogy honest
trailer out we're gonna be doing a
review for Jason Bourne but I thought
you know will be a fun refresher an
honest trailer refresher of the Bourne
trilogy watched the first three all over
again last week in preparation to do my
review with John or the fifth
installment have a strong feeling
there's gonna be a montage of a lot of
moments of what is Treadstone
transference in this dress oh my god my
god Jason pull oh my god Jason Bourne
let's do
before you get bored again we visit the
trilogy that made the world realize give
them Google money to kick some serious
yeah experience the gritty realistic
world of the Bourne franchise full of
bone-crunching action that feels like
it's really happening
spy technology that feels grounded in
reality and the signature camerawork
that feels like someone strapped a GoPro
to a bed second one Jason Bourne the spy
who made that air is James Bond look
like a joke he's on a sucessor with the
skills of Liam Neeson and take it with
the brain a Dory and Finding Nemo
identity looked old something's wrong
with you who's forgotten everything
except all the useful stuff like how to
weaponize an entire Staples got law it's
super Friday I'll give you $10,000 for
driving me to Paris oh yeah a bunch of
other skills that don't seem very
relevant I can tell you the license
plate numbers
six outside I can tell you that what
school his signature move the old come
alone you come alone federal law come
alone
slip away I'm gone oh yeah
so revisits repulse now a thrill ride
that couldn't be more different from
those long boring books on sale at the
airport the Bourne Identity
we're born tries to figure out who he is
has a cool car chase and runs from a
control room full of people on computer
Genesis to discover the government guy
chasing him was just a puppet for
someone else
yup the one suppress a baby boy tries to
figure out why chase chase again was
just a puppet or so tries to figure out
who made it who he is as a cool car
chase and runs the control room full of
people computers only to discover that
the crooked government guy cheats again
was just a puppet for someone else
hey that ain't broke don't fix it story
Jason bought grumpy old bad cameos Tommy
Lee Jones 10 Things I Hate About spy
letter God control
that's right jeremy renner Bourne movie
existed you did - nope we were just
watching by zero that's watching look
you look really cool I wrote down my
little board formula let's hear it this
is gonna include the latest Jason Borman
it's all in there all this stuff that
honest you pointed out it's on this new
one - I'm really surprised the honest
traders in touch on this like how every
other scenes about Treadstone this on
that and it ultimatum it's we got a new
version interesting blackbriar writer
that everyone asked what is it who's
running it who's running it I wanna say
everyone it's just Jason Bourne y-you
know the and whoever is talking to
Bourne remember stuff about him that
makes him want to come out of
he usually has like a memory or two yeah
I'll have like a flash you just gotta
know what it goes through like hey
awesome entering back into the states or
going through the CIA's it just to find
out some answers to this flashback he
keeps having the director who's in
charge of some mission wants born dead
no questions asked Chris Cooper Brian
Cox Tommy Lee Jones in the new one who's
the Davis yeah and they're always like
someone who's involved in Treadstone
can't let them know about my involvement
dredged it towards me kill me a woman
takes pity on born that issues like that
top person at the CIA it's never a guy
in the CIA it's always a woman and a
leader yeah the car chase sequences like
what they talked about here the asset
bring in the asset like a Glock in the
newest one when they said that the
assets never have names we're just
called the ass they're usually played by
a really respected actors yeah why Bowen
bones was in collar and now vincent
cassell someone's usually trying to like
say like you're born you should still
come in you know yes this says or does
something to go he's not something witty
to show he's not coming back someone
usually says oh my god or Jesus Christ
six born insane high tech hacking skills
every movie gets more and more and you
know honestly I want to talk about the
born and the Jason Bourne review is like
they do do it to a point where I'm like
wow they really did that like broke it
down into hacking into certain things
that was really impressive cuz I was
like that seems like how people could
actually do it pretty nuts man I wonder
how how much techno realism there is in
there because it always feels plausible
warrior watching the international
travel born usually has a a moment where
he's face to face with the director of
whoever's been trying to get him kill
this whole time Bourne gets the answers
to his flashbacks and then in like a
couple of sentences then goes on the
go off the Caribbean always gets like an
oddly satisfying and emotionally heavy
answer it's like an answer to his memory
yeah yeah I really just don't get why
born doesn't just stick around like [ __ ]
Woods is one person for a while like can
you just can I let me know about my past
so I can stop having a memory and
causing all this guys I just get all my
answers now I'll never come back because
born maternity that's gonna be for
eternity
he's board's mom we've never heard
mention of her she's probably founded
trends are usually the head of the head
of whoever is trying to like take down
born usually has some type of southern
charm to them like a pinch of southern
charm yeah yeah yeah they're always like
a little bit of music yeah they knew
this was coming yeah
a bunch of dudes living in yeah I know
I'm gonna die someday Jason Bourne's
probably gonna have some well we're
gonna do a review for Jason Bourne
right now the fifth movie skipping
legacy so keep a lookout for that it's
probably up right now actually if you're
new to this channel subscribe today
rejected itis is the word that I used to
use on this channel jon is Jerry reasons
to Jerry and yes he's a social meaning
social media game the government he's a
social media manager of facebook.com
slash blue house but he also runs the
hell out of facebook.com slash the real
rejects go over there guys if you want
to work postman was the articles and
[ __ ] yeah John's on top of that and I'm
gonna give a shout out to Jason Bourne
Jason come in if you receive this
message know that we have answers we
know you want answers we can help Jason
you know you've always been a cinephile
you want to talk
that was call him a patriot and
something committed to the delivery of
that it would have been funnier I'm
sorry
comedy lesson 101 you know I was $100
for my seminar one hour some hundred
dollars really good let's do it teach me